[Music]
traditional pomp and ceremony announced
the arrival of nicolas maduro to deliver
the annual president's State of the
Nation Address but for the fifth year in
a row the ceremony didn't take place in
the legislature but in the chamber next
door the Constitutional Assembly a super
body created by Maduro to bypass the
until now opposition controlled
parliament we invite European Union the
United Nations the African Union and all
the organisations of the community of
Latin American states and all world
organizations come and see how the
people of Venezuela choose their
National Assembly this year 2020 doors
are open to international accompaniment
welcome welcome
[Music]
outside supporters danced and celebrated
but opponents and at least 60 countries
accused Maduro of rigging the polls
including his 2018 reelection amid
strong international criticism and
economic sanctions he said he was open
to providing more guarantees of
transparency is raising the stakes by
summoning the mainstream opposition to a
so-called a dialogue table just days
after their leader won wide or said that
negotiations were out of the question
because there are no conditions for them
and making those conditions even more
difficult for my god to swallow
Maduro is suggesting that even deputies
who the opposition considers traitors to
their cause sit down at the same table
porque no mr. simple y ou told us upon
boycott elections unless there's an even
playing field
una files elección un paseo a fake
election is a placebo it's not a real
approximation towards an alternative
because we could end up validating a
dictatorship and it would be very
dangerous for Venezuela and as the
political standoff heats up ordinary
Venezuelans continue struggling just to
survive in what was once Latin America's
most prosperous country who see a new in
Al Jazeera Caracas